général paul aussaresses bonsoir vous
étiez le coordinateur des services de
renseignement alger en 1957
vous avez participé à des actes de
torture non mais vous avez participé à
des exécutions sommaires oui vous avez
exécuté combien de gens donc je les vis
la jeune alice crime aux internautes des
serres du monde florence baylet j'ai je
jamais exécuté 24 est ce que comme le
capitaine nous avons entendu tout à
l'heure vous avez des héros morts non
pourquoi
parce que je n'ai procédé de tels actes
que dans le cas de d'individus qui était
reconnu comme ayant participé à des
actes de terrorisme
mais pour autant s l'honneur d'une armée
que d'exécuter que de tortures et non
non non alors vous devriez en avoir des
regrets vous devrez vous dire c'est pas
comme ça qu'on mène la guerre écoutez
nous n'avions pas le choix il y avait et
dans la bataille d'alger un nom il ya eu
un nombre très considérable d'actes de
terrorisme et d'actes qui a mené la mort
d'innocents de femmes et d'enfants plus
que des militaires
et lorsque nous avions capturé certains
auteurs de ces actes eh bien nous
sentions de reconstituer la filière qui
leur a fait perdre l'organisation qui
leur avait permis et d'avoir la
possibilité d'accomplir ses actes les
lois de la guerre autorise la torture
d'après vous djerba
alors pourquoi et bien parce que les la
justice à l'époque était impuissante
décider du sort de ces auteurs d'actes
de terrorisme à vous exécutiez les gens
très vite donc la justice avait pas le
temps de s'en mêler la justice n'aurait
pas eu le temps
nos études du temps de garder ces gens
emprisonnés mais il aurait fallu des
mois des mois avant qu'ils puissent
faire l'objet d'une enquête d'abord et
ensuite un jugement général d'autres
militaires n'ont pas choisi comme vous
d'exécuter ou de torture est certain je
pense au général de bollardière ils ont
refusé et france la portée de jeunes
aussi qui a refusé pourquoi est ce que
vous n'avez pas refuser parce que gp
soumis à des conditions je connaissais
très bien
le général de bollardière dont j'avais
été l'adjoint direct en indochine et
c'était un homme que je considérais
comme remarquable alors pourquoi vous
n'avez pas suivi son exemple et parce
que gpg n'était plus sous ses ordres
j'étais aux ordres du général juge gémir
le vaudois bière avait 1 common man à
proximité d'alger mais il n'était pas
impliqué dans la bataille
le général massu n'a pas la même
position que le général bigeard vous
êtes plutôt proche du général massu qui
il faut le reconnaître est faux choix
aller jusqu'à une forme de repentance ou
pas non non pas léger j'ai je ne suis
pas en peur ni forme de repentance et
pourquoi
et parce que est une forme de repentance
pour des actes criminels ne se justifie
pas 90 une forme de réponse en soi bien
sûr est quelque chose de louable mais
lorsque il s'agit d'actes criminels et
bien j'estimé ligne a pas lieu d'avoir
un cours à une repentance mais vous
pensez qu'on peut encore quarante ans
après plus de quarante ans après
justifier la torture utilisées par les
mutins france a justifié mais va
constater et le journal de france
version en algérie il ya des familles de
ceux que vous avez exécuté mais il y à
des familles de personnes qui ont été
torturés
oui qu'est ce que vous leur dites
jamais de bombay et si je vous demandais
si vous disais nous avons un devoir de
mémoire un devoir d'histoire à faire
retirer
eh ben je l'avais que oui vous avez un
devoir d'histoire
en ce qui me concerne personnellement
mais en ce qui me concerne j'ai été dans
des conditions où j'ai eu recours à des
actes que je n'aimais pas et que j'ai dû
remplir général un militaire doit
toujours obéir même dès lors qu'il
s'agit d'enfreindre tirait des lois
humaines écoutez les militaires dans la
plupart dans tout l'éclat d'un tout
l'éclat auquel j'ai des mails et
d'exécutions sommaires et de juste d or
dire que je n'ai pas exécuté moi même
mais que j'ai approuvé et bien le
militaire rendez compte à sa hiérarchie
vous dites maintenant on aurait pu faire
autrement
tu as l'habitude de dormir vous
comprenez donc d'une certaine manière
qu'on puisse torturé en bosnie en
afrique en argentine mais lorsqu'il se
passe un a pris grand bosnie et en
argentine ne me concerne pas ce qui
marque concernée était la bataille
d'alger et je me suis trouvé dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas celles
d'argent team de bresse mid est
d'ailleurs que doit faire la france
d'après vous essayer de réparer une
certaine manière non alors il faut
passer passer l'épongé sur des milliers
de victimes
à mon avis il faut passer les branches
et pas savoir reconnaître l'histoire
je vous ai dit que j'avais été amenés à
pratiquer des exécutions sommaires dans
le cas où j'ai eu affaire à des
terroristes coupables d'actes qui va
mener la mort d'innocents et il avait
été p il faisait l'objet
d'interrogatoires mais vous n'avez aucun
regret j'ai n'ai aucun regret si j'ai
des regrets mais je n'ai pas vraiment
merci gênant